good afternoon everybody it's mike
vaultos from order flows and welcome to
today's presentation i'll get started uh
it's about four o'clock so i'll get
started in about 10 or 15 seconds here
just uh going through a couple last
minute checks make sure
my sound is working fine making sure the
speaker's on um sorry the microphone is
on and that you can hear me and that you
can see my screen okay so just bear with
me and i'll get started uh
fairly soon
okay looks like everything is going
according to plan you know i always got
to check this sometimes uh
you know there's
make a little mistake and you can't hear
me or you can't see my screen so if you
can't
hear see my screen or hear me just let
me know but daniel says everything looks
good on his end so i'll get started so
today what i want to talk about is the
order flows turns now
you know
we have
the order flows trader software which is
the volume footprint chart but
you know not everybody wants to use a
footprint chart personally i think the
footprint chart is
you know
a trader's best friend
but
you know over the years we've
indicatorized some of the ways that i
look at order flow and the order flows
turns is one that we released a few
years ago and you know is is still to
this day still performing well you know
we've have users that have been using it
literally since uh since we launched i
think it was 2017 so you know it's
coming up on
was that four years already and you know
every once in a while you know somebody
says hey mike you know can you add this
little feature or you know change this
and you know well it's slow to do it you
know if it's a one-off um you know i'll
put them in touch with my programmer but
if it's something that i think can
benefit everybody you know we like to
put it in the software but
earlier this year we did a upgrade of
the turns and i'm going to talk about it
a bit today and what i really want to
get into is um
you know really what the turns is and
and how it can help you in your trading
and sort of the logic behind it you know
how it came about so you know before we
begin just a brief disclaimer you know
we all have seen these disclaimers you
know trading is
risk management basically you know don't
trade with money you can't afford to
lose
so the agenda for today again i i want
to keep this you know about an hour long
i don't keep everyone on all day and
what i'll be talking about is several
things the first thing is i'll talk
about support and resistance
versus supportive buying and resistance
selling and i'm gonna talk about what is
supportive buying and resistant selling
and what it means to the market right
we've all heard of support and
resistance but we don't really think of
supportive buying and resistance selling
okay i'm going to show you how to spot
i'll talk about which markets are more
effective for trading it and lastly i'm
going to talk about the order flows
turns and how it can help you process
what's happening in the order flow to
see that support of buying and resistant
selling
so you know just the first thing we all
we all heard of support and resistance
right we all know what support and
resistance is um you know everyone likes
to show charts and you know just you
know just really briefly people will
show charts oh there's there's
resistance up here because we came up
here and tested you know a certain level
um let me
get this laser pointer here
you know people
it's it's a bit lazy people will say you
know there's there's resistance selling
um happening because you know we've
touched a level
earlier you know and they'll say
hang on a second here make this
crosshairs
uh black so it's easier to see
just give me a second
back there we go
you know people say well there's
resistance up here right because you can
see where it came back up traded there
and came off from it okay well
you know honestly
you that's a cheap way of calling
something resistance just because the
market traded up to a price you know
here you have you know a very long wick
you don't know what caused that spike up
there or if it was legitimate um
resistance right when you think of
support and resistance right it's size
basically
right it's
there there's a strong
bid for support or there's a strong
offer for selling so you know if the
market just pokes up there and trades
three contracts
is that really
resistance or is it just a price probe
now
you know
it's getting a bit into semantics you
know as a trader really all you're
you're interested in is how the market
reacts but what i want to talk about
today is
the difference between support and
resistance and support of buying and
resistant selling because there is a
difference
and
when markets move right they move on
aggressive buying or aggressive selling
right aggressive buying is traders
lifting the offers right
that's what aggressive buying is right
you have people working bids you have
people working offers but for the market
to trade
someone has to
buy the offer right someone has to cross
the bid offer line or someone has to
sell into the bid right they have to hit
the bid right the market's traded in a
two-way auction
now
what sort of gets lost in that is the
counter trade you know people will say
well you got aggressive buyers here
right if you for example if you look at
a footprint chart
you know
a normal footprint chart you're going to
see where the aggressive selling is
where the aggressive buying is and
that's all well and good but really what
you want to be seeing is
where
the passive buyers if they're coming
into the market
okay because what does that mean so
imagine the market is going up
okay people are buying the offer right
that's what you expect but if you see
big bids coming in and people selling
into those bids but those bids are
absorbing all that selling then the
market ticks higher and you see more
buying coming in not aggressive buying
but support of buying you know a new bid
coming in people are selling into that
bid someone is absorbing
all of that selling right and and the
same is true on a market that's starting
to to go lower
all right you have
you know a move up
okay
you have aggressive buying coming in but
then when someone is offering out some
supply
you know
it sort of stops that move up right then
as the market starts to tick down
right you still have aggressive buying
coming in but there's more
passive selling absorbing that buying
that aggressive buying that's coming in
sure you'll see aggressive selling come
in also right that's what you want to
see for the market to move down
that's what causes the market to move
down but imagine someone is putting
their hand on top the market
and absorbing all the buying that's
coming into the market that's what
resistance selling is
now
can you see it on a normal bar chart
well
it's it's honestly it's it's kind of
difficult right if you're just looking
at
where's my chart here if you're just
looking at a normal bar chart
you can't right this is a candlestick
chart right can you really tell that
there's
resistance selling or their support of
buying down in here right you're just be
guessing because what do you need right
you need to dig deeper into the bar
you need to see the order flow right you
need to see what is
transacting you know at these prices
down in here right what's traded on the
volume on the bid what's being traded on
the offer right then you got to put it
together right and understand that yeah
this is
important buying right this is the ultra
bonds this just a few hours ago around
12 o'clock
right you can see there's nice
aggressive buying as well as supportive
buying coming into the market and the
market squirts up a few ticks right
immediately right after that
but if you're looking at a normal bar
chart you can't figure that out
right you just can't see that
information
that you that you're looking for right
so
that's why using an order flow footprint
chart is going to help you but again
there are people out there that don't
want to use a footprint chart and i
understand that right i've understood
that ever since i started using a
footprint chart because until i
understood what i was looking at
honestly i thought it was just you know
over i'll say overwhelming but i'm like
you know what what's the point right you
know i'd be looking at a chart like this
you know
back in the days you know years and
years ago when when these things first
came out
and you know you're sitting there you're
trying to you know sort of understand
you know
how to make heads or tails of of what
you're seeing here in the order flow
right it was a lot of trial and error
and you know a lot of traders
struggled with it and to be honest and
you know over the years there's been a
lot of
people that have adapted adopted it
rather to their trading and you know now
they find that the market makes uh
perfect sense to them because they could
understand what's happening now you know
understand about order flow okay it's
it's not about picking every single turn
in the market sometimes there's
information that you can
trade off of
other times it's just you know the
market doing what it's supposed to do
right facilitate trade that's why the
markets were
created
you know since
centuries ago you know 1800s or some was
even say
in japan and in the 1600s or even
earlier
you know for for
people to
transfer risk right from one party to
another basically to facilitate trade
and the markets go up and down
to find sort of that balance where
buyers and sellers are happy
okay so
you know what with that said
what markets are more effective for
trading
with order flow basically
you know there's
in the us there's about 50 actively
traded markets right
you throw in another 25 you know from
around the world right in urex um
euro next you know even even in asia
there's markets australia's got markets
uh
brazil honestly i haven't looked at
brazil but you know there's a lot of
futures markets out there that you can
trade okay so
you don't have to stick to
the stock indices right
y e-s-n-q-y-m
you know if you go on twitter or you go
into some of these facebook groups you
think that this those are the only
markets in the world right because
everyone's posting charts of nq
you know or es and that's all everyone's
talking about well
you know expand yourself a little bit
right while those are
decent markets to trade you know i call
them okay markets they do have their
drawbacks right there's a lot of
you know especially in the e-mini s ps
you know there's there's a lot of type
of trading that you just don't see in
other markets one yeah you have a lot of
algos right but honestly um
you're not competing with the algos okay
they're
doing their own thing
but you get a lot of arbitrage between
different markets you know with the es
even with the nqym
getting a lot of delta hedging
but
if you can expand a little bit and start
looking at other markets
right you can take away a lot of that
activity and all of a sudden you're left
with markets that
rely more on supply and demand right
because they're driven more instead of
by you know these um
i don't know i can't think of the word
right now you know instead of being
driven by
all this funny money so to speak yeah i
use that term loosely um
you know it's more supply and demand
driven because it's driven by the
commercials or it's driven by the
producers you know people that are
buying this because there's a need for
it or you know they have to
you know whether it's you know a grain
you know if you're trading a grain
contract or you know an oil seed
contract you know there's
you don't have
you know that that big participation by
hot money coming in and just dumping it
because oh you know it was it was the
play of the day or something like that
um you know it's it's driven more by
people that are are using it um as a
hedge or
trading it because you know they they
need to
refine it or use the product to
manufacture something right you don't
have that in es or nq or ym
so much so you know what are some of
those markets obviously the grains are
great contracts you could look at um
the bonds you know even even crude oil
right i mean even though there's a lot
of speculative money in crude oil
relative to some of the lesser markets
you know it does follow supply and
demand better you know the problem with
es and nq is
you know the fed keeps printing money it
feels like it's just free money and
interest rates are zero so everyone's
just piling in to es and nq right every
time it looks like es and nq is about to
sell off the market just rallies right
market could be down in the morning all
of a sudden it closes on its new
lifetime highs because people realize
the fed's just
not gonna raise interest rates probably
for the next year or two so
we'll put it in stocks
um you know so it's
yeah i just find that there's markets
out there that
lend themselves better to
order flow okay
so
let's take a look at a chart real quick
here we'll take a look at um
e-mini's today okay so
yeah early this morning let's say early
this morning you know around nine or ten
you know it was kind of quiet in the
e-minis um earlier in the day
and
yeah your range trading basically okay
if you remember you know
we
were basically trading around 86 87 you
know down to 85 right and
it was a very tight market um
for that period okay and when you're in
a tight market you know a consolidating
market right you know markets tend to
bounce around um between support you
know i hate say support resistance but
you know they're in a tight range and it
seems like they're bouncing off support
and resistance and really what the
market is doing when it's in a
con a tight range consolidating whatever
you want to call it is this facilitating
trade
okay and that's what the markets exist
to do right facilitate trade it's when
the markets start to move out of an area
right you can see here right we're in
this range right between 85 and 88
more or less trading out we try to trade
above
and then it sells off a bit back down
you know down
to you know 81 um back
and then trades
it bounces off 80
was that 81 and a quarter um and then
just slowly grinds it was just it was a
grind for
um
i felt like a grind for for most of the
day right and it's just hanging around
back up to 80
what is that 87 88 you know back down to
86 back up to 88
um you know then sort of started working
its way down again
back down to 81 okay
so
it
the thing is
you know people don't understand when
it's easy to look back on a chart and
say oh yeah well the market was
consolidating you know it's range bound
well yeah but
if you're you're trading it
live you don't know if it's range bound
or not right because
you know every time it starts to sell
off you're thinking well this is it
we're going to start sell
then every time it starts to rally
oh this is it they're gonna start
rallying up again you know we're gonna
make new highs or not but if you know
where there's supportive buying coming
in or resistant selling coming in
then you know it's gonna help you
understand that no this market's not
going to you know really
go much lower so for example here right
earlier this is around 10 15.
there's resistance selling coming into
the market here again we this is the
range that we've been in um
you know between 88 and 86 or 84 84 to
88 um you know for you know since nine
in the morning right then we come up to
88 and i see resistance selling coming
in okay come back we don't really sell
off very much come on you know we rotate
down to 84. rotate back up to that area
87. more resistant selling coming in
right
so
you already know right from earlier
there's
resistance selling you know basically
between six and a half and eight right
and then you sell off a little bit you
know you sell off
four points right a normal rotation well
what do you think is going to happen if
we come back up around 87 and a half
right it's going to be you're going to
look for more resistant selling coming
into the market okay
now this is you know we're talking
resistance selling coming in at around
the 86 and a half 87 area
then where do you expect the resi
supportive buying to come in right 84
right which is sort of that area that
we're in
you know before back at you know nine
to ten o'clock okay we did get through
it down here to 84 and a half but you
know 84 and a half to 85 and a half more
or less
um you know it's sort of where you're
looking for right and you can see it did
stop there a little bit then it got
through okay he didn't see any real
supportive buying coming into the market
to support this market and it got
through there right it sold off down to
80 um and three quarters 81
and just sort of hung around right and
then you see later right remember this
area here 81 this was at 10 30. we come
back in here
or just after 11
now you see support of buying now
let me ask you if you're looking at this
order flow right just looking at the
footprint can you tell
well
if you've been looking at order flow
long enough and you understand how order
flow works
yes you can tell right you can
understand that based on the volume
that's being traded on the bid and the
offer
you know and relative to how it's been
trading recently
yeah you can tell okay but if you just
you know if
i don't say if you're new to order flow
but if you know you're not familiar with
what to look at
then
you can't right you can't tell i mean
it's only as good you know it's like a
doctor i i could look i can go to the
hospital get an x-ray done and i could
look at it
and think i'm fine but the doctor will
look at it and he's like no you can see
this here that there i don't know and
that's how it is sometimes with with
order flow for
a lot of traders is they look at it and
they scratch their head and okay yeah if
you say so mike so that's why
we created tools like the order flows
turns okay is to highlight these bars
that have that
supportive buying right that have that
resistance selling coming in
okay so that you know you can you can
use it to trade off of right because at
the end of the day right if you don't
know that there's resistance up here
then
you know you might find yourself buying
it right imagine you're you say oh well
the market just you know it's just
rallied up from you know 81 down here um
all of a sudden you know just rallied
all the way up to
86 you know 87 almost you know here we
we hit 87 87 and a quarter oh this is it
we're going up but you know
in the back of your mind you should be
thinking you know there's some
resistance selling in here you know
because a lot of times people say well
the market's in a consolidation right
it's tight and so
you're just waiting for that move to
happen right i love consolidating
markets because
that's oftentimes where you get the big
moves coming out of but at the same time
you know markets can consolidate
for you know longer than we anticipate
right so you're trying to buy you know
if you're trying to buy in here and you
buy it at you know 87 you know does it
go up yeah it goes up to 88 and a half
then it just you know comes back down
it's just burning a hole in your pocket
before it just sort of grinds you down
to you know you're saying well you know
you're like well i'm holding it you know
i'm long from 87 i'm still in the money
there it goes now back up to 88 and a
half
and then you know then what you know you
just wasted your whole afternoon waiting
for a breakout
that never came
right but if you know there's resistance
up here then
you can you can take advantage of it
basically
right and again you know today is kind
of an abnormal day it's very
tight market um
you know
this whole year it's been uh normally
the market's been putting in a lot of
directional trade but nevertheless
knowing that you have resistance up here
right if you were long and you're
running up in here now it's very obvious
because you have something on your
computer telling you you know there's
resistance up here
you can get out or you get short right
you're already it's 2 30 in the
afternoon you know you're running back
up into resistance and you're getting
short up here on you know 87 and a half
87 and three quarters
down into the cash close you know
basically you know down to 82. there
wasn't very many moves to be had today
so to get five points out of a move
today is good but you know this is five
points right here in the e-minis today
on a pretty uneventful day now
earlier right i was saying
there's a lot of other futures contracts
out there to trade now i just showed you
the e-minis but i want to spend some
time talking about other markets and you
know a market that doesn't get its its
respect i guess is ultra bonds right now
this is ultra bonds here um this is a
footprint chart
right and honestly this is just a one
minute chart and for some people
especially newer
people to order flow
right it's a little bit difficult to
make out of a market that
seems to be trading
very little volume now people get
discouraged because oh you know i can't
trade this market you can see here this
in this one minute period only traded
one contract or here it only traded um
basically one price at 0.5 it was five
bid
at six and it only traded
17 lots on the bid then it went offered
at 05 it was four bit at five only the
bid didn't even trade it just traded the
five offer
so it's a little bit difficult for some
people
to trade markets like this because you
know they don't understand order flow
honestly and it does take a little bit
of
getting used to
you know people say well you gotta
spend ten thousand hours of screen time
you know i i think that's a bit
excessive you know ten thousand hours to
spend in front of a screen
it was like what
five years
you know you figure you work eight hour
day
40 hours a week 50 weeks in a year
that's 2000 hours so that's like what
five years you know
you can't right it's just not humanly
possible unless you make it your
full-time job to stare at a screen for
eight hours
um
but if you had a tool that's telling you
you know there's some support in the
market here
you know
you can add it
to your trading arsenal so to speak
right and and understand what's
happening in the market now
again
on a candlestick chart you can't see it
that's where a tool like the order flows
turns comes in because now
you could add it to your candlestick
chart all right
and you can see
where
this resistance selling comes in where
the supportive buying comes in
all right now i know some people
if i get an email on this later or
somebody will comment on
on the replay you know if i post it up
on on facebook or something
um let me just change the crosshairs
here
to black and someone said well you had
this trade here it was a loser well
you should already been long from down
here not getting long after
um you know half a basis point move
almost the whole point move you know
basically from 23 all the way up to
you know 20
up here but
having a tool
that's going to put it on your bar chart
means you don't have to read what's
happening in in this right you don't
have to try and figure out make heads or
tails of what's happening in this order
flow right because now
you could just put it on your bar chart
so you know if you're using something i
don't know you know a lot of people use
like to use indicators you know v-web or
other things
then
imagine you know if you have
your your own tool right
that's telling you you know what what
you should be looking at in the market
okay
um
you know
your own forms of analysis so to speak
then
it's just going to help you out a lot
right because now
yeah yeah what's going on with this
ninjatrader um
now you can see
areas of interest you know and see if
there's supportive buying or supportive
selling
happening at those areas
so
but you know that that's where having a
tool like the order for those turns is
going to help you
okay
now
let me just uh
gotta love it let me just take a look
here at some questions um
this question here is this webinar live
yes it is live
those red and blue bars are those supply
and demand zones well yeah i don't want
to think of it as
supply and demand
zones because basically what they are
they're they're levels
and
you know with
with um
okay rather i don't call them levels
what i call it is these
red and blue bars that you see on the
screen
right
that's telling me the conditions are met
for
a potential turn in the market
okay now
in
in the old version
okay i mean in the original version
of the order flows turns
and you know many of our indicators and
actually many of the indicators that are
out there
is
what you see is
you see in
a signal okay and
the the problem with that is you see a
you see a signal
and automatically people turn into red
light green light traders oh there's a
there's a bicycle i got to get long okay
so what you're seeing with those blue
and red zones
are areas
where
conditions are met in the order flow
okay
and
rather than just kicking off a signal
straight away like oh there's
there's um
you know there's a oh hang on a second
here you know there's
you know rather than basically turning
you into a red light green light
trading
give a second here i had to restart an
integer
rather than basically turning you into
something that's red light green light
okay
in the sense that oh my gosh you know
the conditions are met i got to get long
what we have and i'll explain that in a
bit is a trade entry signal
that
basically
you know helps you understand that
conditions are met for
a buy or a cell however
there's no trade signal yet right
because what you want in addition to
just having the conditions met in the
sense that yeah i can get long or i
could get short here
is there follow-through order flow
right is there something in the order
flow
that's telling me yeah this market is
going to continue in that direction and
that's where you see
the
um
the triangle the up triangle for a by or
the down
down triangle for a cell
okay
now
hang on a second here
so hopefully you know i'll explain that
in a minute um
or two but just bear with me here i'm
going to
get to that i just want to get to a
couple questions here mike i need help
okay
well i'll check bob you should have
gotten in that already but um
okay
uh uh
i'll check my emails bob
um because you're asking about power
bars um
but uh
i'll get to that i'll make a note here
to
get back to you on that
um
okay brian asks i have delta surge flow
scalper what's the difference on the
signals and does turn get me closer to
the pivot bar than the others
okay
okay well
the turns
is different you know whenever we
release an indicator
it's always different right it looks at
different
parts of the order flow right there's
so much of
bob just do me one favor just
message me your email address um that
way it's a little easier to find
sometimes
but brian getting back to it there's
so many different
parts of and aspects of
order flow
that
you don't need to rely on on one thing
now delta surge right it looks at
increases in delta
okay
over several bars right and the delta
search is the free indicator it's
available on on the website order flows
you just go in there
enter your email and download it for
free
and
you know because the question i get a
lot is you know delta surge and delta
scalp are similar no they're not i mean
they both read delta but they read it
differently
okay now
the
flow scalper
is
reads
different part of the order flow now
again you know in order flow you have
delta you have point of control
you have imbalances right you could
focus on one piece you could focus on
two you could focus on all three
and then even within a
you bar
you can
focus on where imbalances are appearing
you know what order flow is like
in certain areas of a bar there's so
many different ways you can take apart
what you're seeing
in the order flow right it doesn't rely
on just
one single piece of order flow okay so
there's
you know many different ways of
splitting it up in terms of analysis
right just as
you know if you think of just looking at
a normal bar chart
okay
there's
you know you got so many different
indicators you could add on but with
order flow all the information is is
right there you can sort of separate it
all these different data points right
and you know it gets lost on people
people say well you know order flow is
just the latest fad well it's not it's
information right and you know it's
information that
now
you know over the last
five ten years the hedge funds right the
big traders
you know they've
they're using that information right
they're writing models based on delta
based on imbalances based on points of
controls and you know so to think that i
you know i don't need to use order flow
it's just you know somebody's you know
it's a marketing gimmick well it's not
right it's information that's generated
by the market
right people say well price is the best
piece of information well prices only
one piece
of the market right
a market you know and that's you know
the perfect example
is
let me see here if i could find a good
example right if you're looking at a
normal bar chart okay
what am i looking at here this is this
is crude all right so what is this is a
one minute chart
people will say well
the market came up here and there's
resistance up here or something because
they see the market traded up there and
it came right back down well
there's actually resistance here
earlier
okay
in this in this crude market right that
caused it to sell off
now
who knows what happened here all right
if you're just looking here on a simple
bar chart you see that big wick up right
and you're thinking well that's it you
know that's
the market can sustain that well why
couldn't it sustain that people say well
there's resistance up there what is
there i know there's resistance here
based on volume okay
maybe that volume got pulled here market
tried to probe higher on light volume
right because if you're going into
resistance you're going to look for
heavy volume right because at the end of
the day that's what causes strong
resistance is heavy volume
right because the market can't go any
higher
right just as if you're at a low
right
you want to see strong buying right here
in the sense of strong bids in the
market right to support this market for
the move back up
okay but again if you're just looking at
a normal candlestick chart
you're not going to see it all right so
you know hopefully that that clears it
up a bit
um john
john asks this is a third or fourth
package with order flow trade if you
presented which one of these is better
yeah it's
don't be confused
because
you know it really depends
honestly i find that
again
traders tend to get caught up in the e
mini
nq world
right and
it's
it's such a small world you know there's
so many other great contracts out there
to trade like i said you know ultra
bonds okay
if you
oops here's ultra bonds ultra bonds is a
great contract for trading
right because
it can follow support and resistance
generally pretty good right all you got
yeah you sell here you buy here right
goes back up
you know that was it you know for the
day there basically you know people say
well this one didn't work yeah okay but
you already got your
you know 10 or 15 points there 10 or 15
points there okay you get stopped out on
this little move here fine
you know i mean not every trade
is
going to be a winner
um
you know there's
ultra bonds just make this chart a
little bit easier to read here
you know yesterday this is a great
market if you're a short-term trader
right trying to you know a tick in the
ultra bonds is uh what 31 25 a tick
you know you could have relatively tight
stops especially if you're trading using
a dome now again i'm not saying that oh
you got to throw out your dome or you
got to throw out your
your other tools that you're looking at
right no you add this
to that trading arsenal
right
and again let me please ninjatrader work
here
it's
ninjatrader's acting up
again
it's a tool that you can use to
help you analyze the market okay and a
lot of people
again
get lost in in the market because you
know they they think that it's
just something that
you know they have to trade this market
because oh i see so and so is trading
you know that's all you see on
facebook or something no you don't have
to do that right there's again there's
there's so many other great markets out
there
that you can trade
ultra bonds is one
um
you know we'll take a look at some of
the grain markets like soybeans uh wheat
you know those markets follow order flow
really nicely if you really want to get
into some of the the
smaller markets uh nat gas is a great
contract to trade
and
you know
soy meals ten dollars a tick you know
again there's nothing wrong with trading
e-minis or nq but you know what i'm
saying is you know expand your
expand your horizon a bit all right
understand that there's
more to the trading world than just
those two little markets okay
so
what the order flows turns does is it
helps you process what's happening in
the order flow to see that support of
buying and that resistance selling right
when you look at a footprint chart again
it's overwhelming at first right and
don't let it overwhelm you to the sense
that
you disregard order flow because again
you know there's there's a lot of
information out there
right and you know as as a trader right
you want to use that information
so again if you're not
i'm not saying that you have to add a
footprint chart to your training you can
buy tools that analyze
the footprint for you
now you know john getting back to your
question
there's different markets like i said
right that
each market has different
characteristics okay
so
you can
add different tools to those markets
right i know
everyone likes to say well if this
indicator is you know so good why why
are you selling it why are you doing
this um you know this and that well it's
yeah that's not how i look at it right i
mean you know there's i've been a
professional trader you know i've worked
at jp morgan for almost a decade you
know prior to that as with cargill with
commerce bank with man um i was on the
cme floor but you know one thing that i
realized in in working with a lot of
people is if you have information
and you're not willing to share it what
good is it
right you have to be able to
share it with other people right there's
i understand there's a lot of people out
there struggle to
make money trading right people say well
you know if you can't make money trading
you know so you're going to teach well i
don't look at it like that right
each one teach one right pass that
information on you know what's good
what good is all this information if
you're just hoarding it right the way i
look at it is
there's enough food out there for
everyone to eat right and you know if
you can't eat right now you come to my
plate and let me show you
you know how i'm doing it to
uh you know myself how i've done it for
um decades right it's not like
you know i see these
other people out there these other gurus
or whatever you want to call them
you know and you look at their
background and say oh you know this one
you know i've been trading for 10 years
well he's been trading
in his spare time
while he's doing something else right
that's not real trading you know the
training that i did was
on a trading desk
six in the morning till 5 pm at night
you know for
a long long time you know decades so you
know really that's why we put these
tools out there is because you know i
want you to understand there's so many
different ways to look at the market you
can look at a market
one way
and you might be successful at it but
you're limiting yourself right that's
why we release other tools is because
you know you got to expand your
knowledge base you know you got to
expand your
horizons so to speak and and go beyond
just that small little
um
you know that small little world right
so
you know just
give me a second here
let's
see if this works
let's see if i can pull up another chart
here ninjatrader is acting a bit goofy
right now
yeah
there we go
so
basically
what i want to show you guys right
okay so let's take a look okay i mean
this is what is this this is crude oil
but
let's just find something else besides
these these markets um
you know these are all the markets that
i look at on a daily basis right people
you know buns stacks
euro stocks even in malaysia palm oil uh
nikai in
in asia
but you know
take a look at wheat okay you know wheat
doesn't get the respect it deserves i
haven't looked at it today but you can
see there's nice moves here in the weeds
right 725 to 735
right what's this what's a one cent move
you know from 725 to 726 in the wheat is
50 cents right that's the same as one
tick in the e-minis so this is a 500
move right here okay so there's nice
moves to be had and with a tool like
i see what's going on
you know what i got my screen
on a different screen so it's not
letting me it would only let me pull it
up on the master screen so it's not let
me add the indicator on here right now
because i got a lot of the software
running
but
give me a second here let me add this on
uh save workspaces
all right so
another question from carlos is you know
am i going to be
recording this presentation yeah it is
recording
so
you know hopefully i can get it up for
you guys on
youtube tonight or and send you the link
for it
but uh just give me a second here to get
the
chart back up
it's
the way i look at it is you know
the more i'd say the more tools you have
the more ways you can analyze the market
but rather
you know the reason why i get into the
details of what support of buying is
what resistance selling is so you can
understand what the order flows turns
does
okay because
there's a lot of these indicators right
people oh this is the macd that's the
rsi and
stuff but people understand what goes
into it
right really what's um being calculated
they say well you know what i got to
look at
macd because i saw this video
and people don't understand oh you say
well you guys just got to trade
the uh macd when it go does this or does
that well you know i'm showing you sort
of the
basis
on what you're looking at
in the order flow right so you could
understand sort of the the whole idea
of what the
order flows turns does
right because you know honestly without
that information
it's
not going to be very effective for you
right because you just be trading blind
right you want to you want to understand
why you're looking at something right to
um you know
basically to to take those trades
okay
so
again um here my charts came back up so
i'll show you
right just really quick
right this is the wheat chart okay now
some people will say well you had a
losing trade here well
now
you have a move here you have this
nice move here yeah you didn't catch the
rest of this move back up but you're
catching
the meats of it you know the meat of it
right here from 727 up into the 730s
maybe you could have caught something in
here catch this move here now again i
have this trade entry signal on okay
so that's signaling only when
there's follow through order flow tell
me to get long or get short okay um
so
under the settings of the indicator all
right
you can see here trade entry signal
right and what that is
is it's telling you
if it's enabled right if there's a check
mark there then it's telling you it's
enabled is the price has to move
at least one tick in the direction
over the next two bars of the trade
signal so what that means is when you
have your
area here right i know there's
resistance coming into resistance up
here right and you get that big bar down
but then it just went inside right it
didn't confirm it with the order flow
that's why you don't see
the red triangle here now of course you
can turn this off right you don't have
to use that so if i were to turn it off
you'd get a signal any time
you know let's turn it off here
any time um the conditions are met
okay so
let's see here
right so now you're seeing the signal
here right signal you know you're not
seeing
um
you're seeing all the signals basically
is when that's on and you know would you
want to use that yeah you can um some
markets i do
right like
ultra bonds i i have it turned on for
every signal
but again it's how you want to use it so
just really quick
let's go over a couple of the settings
in here there's not many settings that
you really have to worry about
there's normal markets and there's
volatile markets okay
normal markets equilibrium level two
normal markets volume expansion right
and then for volatile markets there's
equilibrium level the equilibrium level
and there's also volume expansion now
for most markets almost all markets i
use normal markets right volatile
markets is something i would use like on
dax or if i was using say a 10 range
chart i would use volatile markets okay
but
pretty much all the markets would be
under normal markets it's just volatile
markets you know what what is volatility
volatility is
the market
expand you know sort of
going
vertically looking for
places to trade right that's what
volatility is where the market is
goes
straight up or straight down looking for
an area to trade at
and that's why we have this
extra choice in here for volatile
markets so if you're trading like say a
10 range chart i know people that trade
20 range charts i would suggest they
click that now
turn strength
is really the the indic the setting that
you're going to use the most right it
would be one two three four or five
right you can't do ten
it's just one tooth one is the weakest
you're not going to set it to zero
zero you might as well just not use the
indicator
because there's nothing is going to
happen at zero
but one is the weakest
two and three is about
you know average
four and five
would be very strong
so
yeah i tend to keep it anywhere between
one and three i don't really go above
three
i find when you have four or five it's
too strong but you could also do like
1.5 or 2.5 you know you could do you
know into decimals if you want but
that's just really sort of split into
hairs i find you know the whole numbers
are fine
volume threshold
okay
you can put a minimum volume in there
that you want to appear in a bar right
and
why would you do that well
because you know there's there's some
bars
right like here in the e-minis okay
i think you know this one i've got a
volume filter on
and
if
you know for example
if you have bars that don't have a lot
of volume well
the less volume
is honestly it's going to throw off the
equation but you know you really want
volume you know bars with solid volume
all right you know an e-mini's on a
one-minute chart i find 1000 to be
you know a very decent number
okay
so this is you know how the e-minis were
today on on the one-minute chart
um you know with
a volume of of a thousand
right so
it's you know you're not seeing many
signals in the overnight session because
well
the volume is a lot lighter so if you're
trading the overnight session you know
you'd want to change the
volume
to a different number right a smaller
number but
you can see here i have it set at a
thousand right this is my e-mini
one-minute chart
i use normal markets one
uh equilibrium levels one volume
expansion uh two
now there's another setting in here
delta filter right if you wanna use that
so basically if if the bar
is an up bar it's got to have positive
delta if it's a down bar it's going to
have negative delta
um i have it disabled and there's a
thing here called a look back filter
basically it's looking for swing highs
or swing lows okay
and it's in this case it's set to three
right so it's got
a strength of three in the sense of
a look back filter so for example
all right uh let's just pull up you know
the
e-mini chart from today right this is
today's e-mini chart
it's looking for swing highs or swing
lows
okay so yeah you can see you just go
back
you know the previous day right it's
finding this was yesterday the 23rd
right swing low
to swing high
all right nothing here so another swing
high to a swing low this one
you know then a swing low here
so
that's what the look back filter helps
you
decipher is if there's
you know swing high
swing high swing low swing low right you
it's an additional filter if you disable
it right so for example um
just get it on here
look back filter
if i disable it that doesn't matter what
number i have in there i mean you could
change this if you have it enabled you
could put it at one you know some people
put it at you know 10
it really depends on you but you could
also disable it okay
and when you disable it
what is it doing now is it's going to
give you signals
without taking into account if it's a
swing high or swing low so what that
means is
if it's
you know if there's a move happening
right a move going up or a move going
down
and there's resistance selling right the
market's selling off and you have
resistance selling coming in on that way
down
then it's going to appear
okay so and that is actually quite
useful i i use that
in most markets right now on markets
like the
uh
the equities
stock indices e-minis etcetera i use a
look-back filter but for a lot of the
other markets
um the smaller markets i i don't use a
look-back filter i just go with
um
you know everything but this is the this
is what the look back filter turned off
so you can see there's a lot more
signals now if you're
a very
fast trader right a scalper or something
you know you
if you're trading on a dome
looking just for a few ticks here or
there yeah you might want to turn it off
right because you want to know where
there's potential resistance coming in
okay or where there's potential support
coming into the market right now
again i also have the trade
entry signal turned off here right if i
um
turn it on you know some of these
signals will disappear okay but again
this is you know depending on the market
that you're trading and you know what
you're trading
it's up to you if you want to turn it on
or turn it off okay
but you're going to see a lot more um
signals that you wouldn't see right
because remember this was the e-minis
and before with this swing filter on
right you don't have all these little
these extra buys and these extra cells
in here because these are not swing
highs or swing lows
right really what you're looking for are
those swing highs or swing lows
with the trade with the uh look back
filter now
you know i explained the trade entry
signal to you right you see it's
disabled here
right but if you enable it
the
when the um
whoops
when the signals
appear right you'll have those blue or
red boxes
but
unless there's the follow through order
flow you're not going to have the up or
down the actual trade signal right the
up triangle or the down triangle up here
and you know after you see that here i'm
going to show you you can actually turn
off those
up triangles or down triangles and why
it's important to have the up triangle
or the down triangle is because if
you're using a tool such as markers
and some people use
bloodhound
that's what it's reading right if you
want to automate it now
i don't have time to get into a
presentation on on automating it but it
can be there you can automate these
because it's
it reads that up triangle or the down
triangle
so
again you see here right
the down triangle the down triangle you
don't see the down this right the up
triangle here
right you don't see the up triangle here
you don't see the up triangle here right
because
now it's been disabled in the settings
so
that's the trade entry signal so if if i
want to
disable
the blue and red
zones here right it's i could just go in
here
and
i can disable this right signal box
right that's what it is it's a signal
box just enter 0 0 to disable now all
this is explained in the user guide
right so
um you know you don't have to hear
scratching your head wondering um you
know
what it is but you know let's go back to
you know the settings that i had before
with the look back filter
set to three which is
what i like in the e-minis
so
okay here's the chart
okay so it's just
going through it uh right now
but
again
this it's a little bit flexible on what
you want to use it for you know in the
sense of you know do you want to have
zones drawn out do you not want to have
these zones drawn out it's more of a
visual thing
i like to have them personally
um
because it just sort of tells me hey
mike you know there's
something forming here right now i use
it on a footprint chart not on on a bar
chart but you know
i geek out on order flow right that's
been my thing for
a long time is order flow so
you know if there's something
interesting happening in the oracle
that's how i sort of came about creating
these indicators because at first you
know i was just doing this all manually
in my head by reading the footprint
chart right i would sit here and i would
i would look at
what's happening in here and i could
sort of calculate
in my head it's not like i'm rain man or
anything but you know there's certain
things i'd be looking for in the
overflow to tell me hey mike there's
resistance up here or there's support
down here um but i have in these tools
that's why i like to have these things
drawn just to give me that visual
reference and i could get ready
to trade it if you know if i see that
follow through order flow so now you can
see
right there's no zones just the
triangles here right
that's um you know
what you're looking for right if you're
trying to automate something right you
don't necessarily need to have you know
all these
zones being drawn out you know
like that or anything you just if you
want a clean chart this is about as
clean as you can get right there with
just the triangles
on here
so
again you know that's
basically it
um you know
if you're interested in software i said
right now i got a special going on for
it it's about 35 percent off
um if you have turns from earlier now
someone emailed me earlier i know i just
have a chance to respond to your email
if you have turns from earlier right if
you bought already order flows turns in
the past
the upgrade is free i'm not going to
charge you more for the upgrade um just
you know if you haven't got an email
about it or you know sometimes my emails
go to spam um
people say i didn't get your email and
sometimes just end it up in your spam
folder um you know just shoot me an
email and then i can reply to it and bob
i'll get back to your
question
i said you know personally i see your
email in there so uh i'll
i'll
take care of that after this is done
let me just write this down
let's take a look at one or two more
questions here
a couple more came in
jared asked yeah are the signals exposed
for other strategies to access yes they
are
especially if if you're using
something like
markers i i use markers
was a good time frame for the charge to
get the best signals well it depends on
what you trade now the thing is with
order flow
you know
it's not going to be very effective if
you're trading a 30 minute chart right
because basically what order flow does
is tell you what's happening right now
so you want to take advantage of it you
know honestly i prefer anywhere anything
between a 30 second and
you know
two or three minutes i tend to keep
things between 30 seconds and a minute
some of these faster markets like um ym
or nq or even
the micros i put on a 30 second chart as
well and
in most markets i start with a one
minute chart
right because that's something that's
manageable you know people say well you
should trade a range based chart yeah i
do and i used to trade a lot of range
based charts in the past but
the problems that i found is you know as
the markets get volatile volatility
picks up
you could put in three four bars before
you even
get long right you see something's
happening right now here in the order
flow but if you're on on a range based
chart
by the time your order hits the market
is you jump through especially if you're
trading nasdaq right on bars that that
have 20 point ranges
yeah
you can find yourself
getting in very late sometimes so it
really depends on on on you
um
on what you're looking at phil
uh
okay phil
yeah phil um
i'll get
that sorted out for you you know it's
it's um you know the thing with
ninjatrader people don't realize this
sometimes is
and i don't think ninjatrader is very
open about it is if there's a bios
upgrade on your computer i say you you
know sometimes it i got some computers
it feels like every time i log out it's
asking me to upgrade but if there's a
bios upgrade
when you restart
now a lot of times you don't know it's a
bios upgrade
until you log into ninjatrader and all
your indicators don't work is it kicks
off a new ninjatrader machine id
okay
and
you don't really notice it on your end
especially you know if you have a
fully licensed version or the free
version you don't notice that your
machine id changed right
but if you're on indicators that
is based off your machine id which most
indicators that are
out there that are being sold by other
vendors it's all tends to be linked to
your machine id
so if your machine id changes
the indicators aren't going to work now
you're not going to know that that your
machine id changed because you don't get
a pop-up from ninjatrader it's just all
of a sudden you get your indicators get
pop-ups so again if you
have an upgrade if your computer doesn't
upgrade and sometimes you know i leave
my computer on overnight i wake up in
the morning
and it's been restarted because you know
by windows doing an upgrade um
and you start seeing pop-ups
the chances are it was that bios upgrade
and you'd have to email your vendors
telling you hey i got a new machine id
but phil i'll take care of that
john
well
if you purchased indicators in the past
then
upgrades for that indicator is free yes
right but for that indicator it's not
like if you purchase
you know sometimes people get
into this thing where
um
they bought something else in the past
but then they want
something else in the future it doesn't
work that way unfortunately but john i
know you've got a few of the indicators
i i'm not sure if you have turns but if
you do have turns i'll check and um
you know you get the the new version for
free and the thing with the new version
is you if you already have the existing
license you don't have to
get a new license for it just you just
install it and then
when you
start up ninjatrader again right you
import it as you would a normal
indicator
it all the license already transfers
over so it's like nothing else that
you have to
deal with
jared asked you mentioned a guarantee on
the turns portion of your website can
you elaborate
well
yeah i mean basically you know if it's
not for you
tell me
uh and let's refund your money now
it's funny because as
there's a guy
bought an indicator from me
recently and then
he literally put it on his computer then
eight hours later
opened a case of paypal paypal process
is my pain it's open the case at paypal
saying i don't like this indicator is
the signals because too many signals
okay there's a different indicator not
the turns
okay i went and refunded his money and
you know we just disable the license
because you know if you're not going to
use it disable your license and
you know honestly you got to give an
indicator more than eight hours you know
the guy later came back he's like what
can you
i want to try it for 14 more days i'm
like well i don't have a 14-day trial
you know he goes on and on you know
about this i'm like well if you really
really
were intent on trying it out you would
have tried it out for more than eight
hours
um
you know because you know honestly
indicators
you know or tools you know every market
is different right i showed you e-minis
i showed you ultra bonds but if you're
trading a different market so you're
trading that gas right you have to
um adjust the settings right because
you can't use the same settings that you
would on
ultrabonds that you would on on nat gas
even though you know they're
kind of similar right your strength you
might want to have a different strength
you might want to have a different
volume parameter
right on the e-minis right i was using a
thousand right you can't use a thousand
on crude oil if you use a thousand on
crude oil
you'd get like
two signals
okay but on e-minis you know with the
volume parameter of a thousand you see
you're getting 10 15.
right so you know crude oil i used um a
buck 50 or
i forgot it was 150 or 200
um
i think it's 150 but if i use 150 on
e-mini's well every bar has got at least
150 contracts traded on on a one-minute
chart
but then again if i'm using 150 on
ultrabonds
not every bar is going to have 150
contracts traded so you know it varies
right so there's going to be adjustments
so you know if
you know while we don't offer a trial
anymore um we stopped offering trials
years ago for a different reason but
know you got to try it
for you know different
markets different i hate to say
different settings but you know you got
to tweak it to your market because again
every market trades differently
there's slight nuances that you see in
for example cash settled markets like a
lot of the commodities versus
um actually physically settled contracts
which is like all the commodities
versus cash settled markets
okay so there's these little subtleties
that you that determines on you know
sort of the participation that you're
seeing in the markets um you know again
if you try it for a few days
and you know you're just like i'm not
sure about this you know drop me an
email say mike you know i'm looking at
this market you know on this type of
chart
what do you think right and honestly if
you know if someone were to come up to
me and someone said i use a three-range
chart on crude oil can i use it
it's not going to be very effective for
you okay it really depends on what
you're looking at but again you know at
the end of the day if it's not for you
it's not for you
it's um
it's it's like that that's all
um you know i'm not here to squeeze your
money you know i mean
uh yeah we'll get into stories about
that but you know there's
there's reviews all right i'll just
touch on it right because you know i
don't hide from it but there's reviews
on me on
certain websites futures i o
you know people oh mike also was a
scammer he kept my money well no i
refunded the money it was in the guy's
paypal account
right he thought it was going back to
his credit card but it was in his paypal
account everything's been refunded uh he
kept my money i can't get it out it's
well
there's a processor in between right
there's a party that processes it
the money went back to paypal you pay
paypal paypal pays me i refund it i
refund it to paypal paypal refunds it to
you right so
and most people have a paypal account so
you understand that there's a balance in
there right so you buy something
either yeah you load your paypal account
but if something is refunded it goes to
paypal then you have to withdraw it from
paypal okay sometimes people don't
necessarily understand that but anyway
um i do understand that you know i'm not
out here trying to
squeeze money i'm just you know if i've
got something that i think that can help
you
great right if it's not for you it's not
for you just let me know so anyway guys
i'll end it there for tonight
um
you know if
you have any questions
just shoot me an email honestly i get a
boatload of spam emails i try to go
through everything i must get about 700
emails a day
590 are spam emails but um
you know i try to respond to them
sometimes people say yeah you never
responded sometimes it goes to my spam
folder as well so
anyway
thanks and
let me know what you guys think of the
indicator for those of you that are
interested just go to this website
www.orderflows.comterns.html
so have a great night everybody and i'll
catch you later next week i'll probably
be doing one on one of the other
indicators i think the delta scalper
so
again if you're a delta scalper user um
you might want to tune in for that but
look out for the email on that one i'm
trying to do one presentation a week
covering these different
tools and and how you can use them in
your trading so have a great week
everybody and i'll catch you guys later
bye
you